all right welcome to council geeks my
name is Athena way now I am joined once
again by the co-creators of the webcomic
red and green polsku veto and brian daly
and this time we all got to see x-men
days of future past so we'll start with
the spoiler free version and just quick
summation guys thoughts I watched the
theater happy but that changed oh oh
goodness I was a little bit disappointed
by it um not that it didn't deliver on
was promised I maybe I was just
expecting a little bit more um and I
felt like there were a lot more problems
and a lot more a lot of hit a lot of
things that just didn't add up sort of
logic wise and I'm not even talking
about the time travel aspect even the
time travel part of the story was maybe
the easiest thing to follow um but I
felt like there were some other
inconsistencies with the way characters
behaved in the way certain planes didn't
really come through well have a feeling
some of that will have to get into more
disposed I think I'm gonna be the
dissonant voice of optimism because I my
opinion has not dimmed with time of that
movie I had a absolute blast watching it
and I overall probably it's it's coming
in a tight second for me in the overall
franchise with with first class so I
mean that you know obviously that's me
and we'll we'll draw swords later and
fight to the death and on all this but
um call you you didn't really think I
mean without getting spoilers good it's
a long list oh yeah and it's and it a
lot of it deals with one aspect of the
film that I felt like we did not spend
enough time on and so I felt like there
was they were trying to do a lot in this
movie that's fair and and I think they
missed the mark on some of it one of my
bigger problems with it was had to do
with the characters and a great draw for
the film one of the things that it was
that was building a lot of hype about
this movie was the cast the fact that it
was a reunion of sorts from characters
who we haven't seen together since the
third x-men movie The Last Stand and I
feel like with all of the x-men movies
and there's the out of the seven of them
now we've really only spent a lot of
time with three of them with Wolverine
Professor X and Magneto and in this
movie that had a lot of these characters
most of them were glorified cameos no
and then I would boil down to it was it
wasn't a character it was a power set we
got to see a unique mutants ability to
do something that we hadn't seen before
but we didn't get to know who that
person was and you know that's that's
fair but I think that's a little bit
like what we ran into when we talked
about winter soldier and the title that
I think that's me maybe more of a
marketing issue then with the film
itself I mean in terms of you saying in
terms of the overall franchise yeah I
get that a little bit but I mean I agree
with you that when the marketing was
going on and when we were seeing how
huge this cast was and when every single
mutant got their own cover on Empire I
was like this is ridiculous so actually
I was somewhat relieved by the fact that
they didn't try and give full weight to
all these characters because then it
would have been a complete and total
mess but I i get i get were some
disappointment come in if if you had
bought into the cell of these characters
are back at and or they're going to
interact together because not only were
there a lot of that were effectively
glorify cameos but a lot of them were
working in isolated scenes and never
interactive with the rest of them so I
in my mind though that's a little bit
more on how it was sold in the hype was
built up but but to it excited I think
it was a Fault in the movie in that I
never cared if certain characters were
in danger because I hadn't established a
relationship with the character and if
the Sentinels come down and deliver some
horrible fate to a group of characters
I'm not going to miss any of them
because it's I'm concerning the fire and
teleportation girl and I know the
character is much better than that but
not really from the movie so hey well I
mean I have a counter to that but its a
spoiler so I can't yeah I can't yeah
well I think that's sort of the the
brief sum up we had we had to hoped had
hoped for moors and one very satisfied
so it will we'll take the gloves off
when we come back and do the the
spoiling filled one so tune it back in
for that one and hopefully you've seen
the movie and can can tune in for that